bonsoir à tous voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce samedi et beaucoup de
sport à la une ce soir avec tout d'abord
la victoire et la naissance d'une
championne la jeune serbe ana ivanovic
s'est imposé à roland garros en finale
en attendant demain le choc nadal
federer
et puis le premier match de l'euro 2008
la suisse s'est inclinée 1 but à 0 face
à la république tchèque
il y à quelques minutes hillary clinton
passe la main l'ex candidate à
l'investiture démocrate a apporté son
soutien à barack obama annonçant qu'elle
suspendait sa campagne
le face à face dans la course à la
maison blanche proposera donc le
sénateur de l'illinois au républicain
john mccain
une nouvelle séance folle à la à new
york pour le baril de pétrole plus de 10
dollar de hausse en quelques heures hier
nous tenterons concrètement ce soir de
comprendre pourquoi
et bien sûr nous verrons quelles
pourraient être les conséquences dans
les jours à venir pour les consommateurs
qui sont les satanistes
après les profanations à répétition de
cimetières le grand format de ce soir
s'interroge sur cette nébuleuse pas
vraiment homogène
leur point commun en revanche l'âge 80%
d'entre eux auraient moins de 21 ans
enfin la mort de l'un des maîtres de la
comédie italienne le réalisateurs dino
risi est décédé à l'âge de 91 ans il a
fait tourner les plus grands gassmann un
mastroianni ou encore sophia loren
nous reviendrons sur sa carrière à la
fin de ce journal merci d'être avec nous
on commence donc ce journal par la joie
d'une jeune championne serbe elle n'a
que 20 ans et elle en rêvait depuis sa
plus tendre enfance alors remporté cet
après midi son premier tournoi du grand
chelem
une victoire à paris donc sur la terre
battue de roland garros
dans quelques jours elle deviendra
également numéro un mondial julien
bénéteau et bruno vignais trophée gloire
et beauté
ana ivanovic est la nouvelle reine du
tennis féminin la serbe remporté à 20
ans son premier titre du grand chelem et
devient numéro un mondial
la coupe est bien dans son casier mais
elle a toujours du mal à réaliser
je suis sur un nuage
je suis tellement heureux
je ne trouve pas les mots pour
l'exprimer dans cette finale de
cogneuses face à la russe dinara safina
14e mondial ivanovic mène rapidement 4
jeux à 1
mais la force de caractère est inscrite
dans les gènes de la famille safin
la petite soeur de marat safin ancien
numéro un mondial et égalise à 4 jeux
partout
la brune aux yeux bleus remportent
finalement le premier set 6 4
porté par ce grand coup droit dont la
gestuelle rappelle steffi graf dans la
deuxième manche
ana ivanovic profitent de l'irrégularité
de son adversaire elle s'impose 6 4 6 3
finalement la serbe n'aura eu peur de
trébucher qu'à leur d'escalader les
gradins pour fêter la victoire avec les
siens c'est incroyable quand j'étais
enfant et que j'allais avec mon vélo à
l'entraînement je rêvais que moment la
truelle chassé croisé dans les
vestiaires cet après midi safina et
roland garros ont sans doute été les
témoins du début d'un long règne
et demain c'est bien sûr la finale
hommes qui opposera pour la troisième
fois consécutive l'espagnol rafael nadal
au suisse rodger federer une finale
retransmise sur france 2 rodger federer
qui a peut-être suivi cet après midi la
première rencontre de l'euro qui se
déroule en autriche mais également chez
lui en suisse et c'est son équipe
nationale qui jouait en match
d'ouverture à zurich
un match qui les opposait aux tchèques
et ce sont les tchèques qui se sont
imposés christophe duchiron au coeur de
ce grand cabinet de curiosités qu'est le
stade de foot une fois encore nous
n'avons pas été déçus avec des fausses
blondes à moustache avec des chapeaux à
trous et des fromages de dette
nous sommes en suisse ils ont soigné ici
un peu plus qu'ailleurs la croix et la
manière
à bâle en tribune on manque pas d'air
sur le terrain c'est une autre histoire
oh non pas de souffle mais juste un peu
d'inspiration
les suisses en rouge les chèques en
blanc en première période les suisses
dominent mollement mais quand il tire
soient ses travers soit sur le gardien
le reste du temps c'est tactique aux
tactiques et souvent rasoir l'helvète et
de marbre et le score au repos de 0 à 0
en deuxième période 3 ton on est reparti
pour un tour mais c'est au moment où les
blancs sont au plus mal qu'ils vont se
refaire la cerise à la limite du
hors-jeu le tchèque sverkos n'aura pas
l'occasion de reléguer le ballon au fond
des filets les blancs mène 1 0
puisqu'ils ont montré ça frôle
escroquerie il reste vingt minutes à
jouer
les suisses vont avoir l'opportunité
d'égaliser y en l'occurrence ils tirent
sur tout ce qui bouge et fait un carnage
d'inefficacité
le gardien d'abord et la barre ensuite
empêche le ballon d'entrer dans les buts
l'helvétie s'incline à domicile 1 à 0
c'est injuste mais c'est comme ça et on
va tout de suite prendre des nouvelles
maintenant de l'équipe de france qui est
toujours à vevey dans son hôtel avant de
prendre la direction de zurich pour sa
rencontre de lundi face à la roumanie
bonsoir manuel tissier le temps est un
peu tristoune mais quelle est l'ambiance
côté français ce soir alors l'ambiance
est excellente
aux dires de tous les joueurs que nous
avons rencontré sept derniers jours
notamment dans les points presse elle
est même plus que détendue résumé par
une formule employée tout à l'heure par
sébastien frey on joue ensemble on
rigole ensemble
les bleus sont confinés dans leur nid
d'aigle ici depuis mercredi mais ne
profite pas vraiment de la vue que l'on
dit imprenable sur le lac léman
puisque la météo vous l'avez dit est
épouvantable il ya du brouillard
il pleut régulièrement comme en ce
moment et puis la température sont très
fraîches pas plus de 13 degrés dans la
journée alors on s'occupe comme on peut
dans l'hôtel
raymond domenech et son encadrement a
fait installer une salle de jeux très
complète avec tables de ping-pong les
tournois sont acharnés franck ribéry est
paraît-il l'un des meilleurs à ce sport
et puis le baby foot là ce sont lilian
thuram et patrick vieira qui rivalisent
de cris lorsque leur parti dégénère de
manière incroyable parait-il là encore
les bleus sont donc à 200 mètres d'ici
dans un hôtel totalement interdite
d'accès ils ne sortent que pour les
entraînements aujourd'hui il ya eu un
entraînement à huis clos et les
nouvelles sont bonnes pour patrick
vieira qui a pu s'entraîner tout à fait
normalement normalement si raymond
domenech l'a déjà déclaré forfait pour
le match de lundi il devrait poursuivre
la compétition avec les bleus
bonne nouvelle également pour ribéry
nasri qui était un peu souffrant ce
matin et thierry henry bref tout va pour
le mieux
les bleus vont quitter demain matin leur
cage dorée de vevey direction zurich
pour bondir on l'espère comme des lions
vers leur premier match de l'euro merci
manuel tissier aux etats unis c'est la
phrase de ce samedi une phrase
qu'hillary clinton aurait souhaité ne
jamais prononcer j'apporte mon plein
soutien au sénateur barack obama tout ça
s'est joué à washington en fin de
journée un moment clé dans la course à
la maison blanche suivi par martine
laroche-joubert l'impressionnante salle
du musée national à washington est archi
comble ce matin viennent avant l'arrivée
de hillary clinton elle quitte sa maison
avec près de trois quarts d'heure de
retard sur l'horaire prévu et pénètre
dans le musée accompagné de sa fille
chelsea et 2006 le town l'accueil est
enthousiaste
hilary étreint ses plus fidèles
partisans ému mais elles gardent le sens
de l'humour des sacrements phrase ce
n'est pas exactement la fête que j'avais
prévu et je suis ravi de vous voir enfin
la déclaration attendiez nous devons
mettre notre énergie notre passion nos
forces pour faire tout ce que nous
pouvons pour faire élire barack obama le
futur président loïc féry
au moment où j'arrête ma campagne je
veux le féliciter pour sa victoire pour
son extraordinaire campagne mais je le
soutiens lui donne tout le monde a dit
ne pas regretter le passé aller de
l'avant soutenir barack obama un message
fort hillary clinton se retire avec
panache de la course présidentielle
pendant ce temps à chicago barack obama
décontractée casquette sur la tête par
discuter loin des caméras une partie de
golf une journée de repos avant cinq
mois de campagne contre jeune mc cain et
direction les états unis on le retrouve
notre correspondant alain de chalvron
bonsoir alain alors service minimum ou
pas de la part d'hillary clinton ce soir
on écoute et c'était pas très facile de
faire passer le message ce gars avec
lequel nous nous sommes tant temps
poignet pendant cinq mois et bien c'est
un gars formidable et je vous appelle à
voter pour lui c'était pas facile et je
pense qu'elle a fait beaucoup plus que
le service minimum il ya une bonne
douzaine de à une bonne douzaine de
reprises à la demande et à faire élire
barack obama et elle a eu cette phrase
je demande à vous tous de faire campagne
pour barack obama comme vous l'avez fait
pour moi alors le plus intéressant dans
son discours je dirais c'était la
réaction du public
au début le nom de barack obama a été
applaudi mais aussi conspué à peu près
fifty-fifty 50 50 je dirais à la fin au
bout de la douzième fois où elle
demandait de faire élire barack obama y
avait pu beaucoup de lui et et
finalement c'est ça qui est important
c'est comment ce discours
aura-t-il un thé et interprété par les
électeurs d'hillary clinton et notamment
par les 22% de son électorat qui ont
promis dans les sondages de voter pour
john mccain
s'ils ne rentrent pas dans le camp
démocrate
c'est la chronique d'une défaite
annoncée pour barack obama et qui mieux
qu hillary clinton peut l'aider à
ramener ses brebis galeuses alors alain
vous restez avec nous on va parler d'une
question qui hante l'imaginaire
collectif aux états unis
c'est celle de l'assassinât politique
cette semaine cela faisait 40 ans qu'un
ancien candidat démocrate en campagne
été tué il s'agissait de bob kennedy
c'est une question qui fait l'objet on
sait une attention particulière au tour
de barack obama explications bernard
lebrun valérie le cas jamais sans ses
gardes du corps à distance discret mais
armé est relié en permanence par radio
voici les cinq baux des gars de barack
obama
cinq policiers du service fédéral pour
les personnalités politiques
autrement dit le secret de services en
amérique a le même service secret qui
protège l'actuel président des états
unis d'amérique
george bush la tradition aux états unis
veut qu'un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle bénéficie d'une
protection rapprochée qu après sa
désignation par la convention de son
parti
barack obama lui fait exception à cette
règle
il est sous la protection du secret de
service depuis mai 2007
selon ce spécialiste de la vie politique
américaine le racisme aux états unis
n'est pas qu'un préjugé
c'est une réalité pourquoi parce qu'il
est noir tout de même il est vu comme un
candidat noir et dans mon pays qui a
tout de même plus de 160 millions
d'armes qui circulent qui sont entre les
mains des gens il suffit d'un ce
déséquilibré qui veut marquer
l'actualité il ya 40 ans tu le candidat
démocrate était blanc et s'appelait
robert kennedy en pleine primaire
californienne un jour de juin il fut
abattu à los angeles par un extrémiste
et puis personne n'a oublié en direct
sur les télévisions américaines la
tentative d'assassinât contre ronald
reagan à la huitième semaine de son
mandat présidentiel par un obsédé
d'armes à feu cette violence politique
qui ne rentrent à la culture américaine
le couple obama on est conscient que la
mort le danger vous y pensez souvent
cela ne m'empêche pas de dormir
lorsque la vérité c'est que barack en
tant que noir peut se faire tuer dans
n'importe quelle station service noir et
candidat à la maison blanche barack
obama le sait il n'a pas fini de marcher
avec son ange gardien
on retrouve alain de chalvron alain une
dernière question rapide le candidat
obama at il fait l'objet clairement de
menaces sérieuses ou pas du tout oui
écoutez c'est surtout dans la tête des
gens j'ai entendu dix fois peut-être
surtout dans la communauté noire cette
phrase il sera le candidat parce qu'il
est le meilleur et on nous le tuera
parce qu'il est noir
oui effectivement on ne pense qu'à ça et
c'est vrai ce que disait tout à l'heure
veut la personne dans le sujet c'est
vrai qu'il se trouvera bien
raciste extrémiste pour tenter en tout
cas de le tuer parce que tout simplement
pour lui c'est inacceptable qu'un
candidat noir puissent accéder à la
maison blanche
alors oui il ya eu des menaces c'est
vrai que le service secret est sur les
dents il est très protégé mais vous
savez un candidat dont elle doit être au
contact avec les électeurs donc il ya
aucune protection à 100% mais c'est vrai
que le service secret a obtenu plusieurs
dizaines de menaces ou d'informations
sur d'éventuels sur d'éventuelles
menaces merci alain la france est aux
côtés du liban et l'image vue à beyrouth
aujourd'hui est des plus symbolique
puisque les représentants des principaux
partis politiques français accompagné le
président de la république nicolas
sarkozy le chef de l'état était venu
adresser un message commun au nouveau
président libanais michel sleimane un
message de soutien et d'espoir en
l'avenir portage sur place michaël
darmon philippe turpault lorsque les
chefs de partis arrivent ce matin
l'aéroport de beyrouth
il se pose une question comment jouer le
rassemblement tout en évitant de se
faire manipuler par nicolas sarkozy tout
à fait tombé de la dernière pluie
imagine que j'appelais qu'une tentation
mais au moins c'est pas le sujet ceux
qui voudraient récupérer de façon
politique
tel événement je crois trop près le
peuple libanais c'est une journée
républicaine pour le liban une journée
où on laisse de côté ses phrases
assassines et ses formules qui font
mouche
le socialiste françois hollande
aujourd'hui n'a pas l'air d'en vouloir à
bernard kouchner d'être un ministre
sarkozyste je dois dire qu'il ya
suffisamment de sujets qui me permette
de m'opposer à nicolas sarkozy pour que
au moins sur cette question là nous
puissions sans crainte
vouloir le rassemblement à l'heure du
déjeuner avec toutes les factions
libanaises le plan table et déjà décidé
pour le représentant du hezbollah
c'est jean pierre raffarin qui s'y colle
tandis que nicolas sarkozy essaye de
rassurer les anti syriens inquiets de
son dialogue avec damas tous les pays
ont droit à leur indépendance
au nom de quelle fatalité le liban
n'aurait-il pas le droit à la sienne à
la résidence française nicolas sarkozy
mettant c'est l'unité nationale à gauche
et au centre au résiste comme on peut
tout d'abord on ne rit pas aux blagues
du président
si vous le voulez bien vous pouvez en
fonction de vos affinités discuter avec
tous ceux qui sont ici
j'espère que vos affinités sont
nombreuses pour que personne ne reste au
sol
puis on reste volontairement en retrait
pendant la marseillaise je ne suis pas
non plus d'haïti au point de penser que
le nicolas sarkozy fait les choses
simplement pour la cause qui est la
nôtre
là aussi une opération de communication
pour son premier voyage à beyrouth
nicolas sarkozy s'est approprié le
dossier libanais sur la forme on l'a vu
quand au fond en reprenant le dialogue
avec damas il rompt avec la tradition de
jacques chirac toujours plus haut le
prix du baril de pétrole a augmenté hier
7 x 2 10 dollar en seulement quelques
heures une première la hausse est
désormais de 44 % en un an avant
d'observer quelles sont les conséquences
directes de cette inflation constante
sur les transports aériens
par exemple avec nous pour les trois
questions du jour l'économiste eric
heyer bonsoir pour que l'on comprenne un
peu mieux ce qui se passe tout d'abord
10 dollar de hausse en quelques heures
on est entré un peu dans dans
l'irrationnel s'agit-il ici en fait
uniquement de spéculations ah oui c'est
uniquement la spéculation parce que
effectivement il ya un mouvement
tendancielle de hausse du prix du baril
qui est lié au fait que l'activité dans
les pays émergents est toujours très
soutenu et on sait que ces économies
sont fortement consommatrices d'énergie
de pétrole et donc la demande est
soutenue par c est par ces pays là et
donc le prix du du baril est soutenue
également par cette forte demande mais
ça ça ne le prix du baril devrait situer
aux alentours de 90 $ à 100 $ maximum
est donc là on a vraiment un supplément
qui est liée à la spéculation ça très
très très très très fortement une
question qui intéresse tout le monde
bien évidemment les particuliers comme
les professionnels cette hausse va se
répercuter obligatoirement à la pompe
prochainement n'ont alors pas
obligatoirement alors fort heureusement
le le prix à la pompe est beaucoup plus
inerte que le prix du baril et si c'est
juste un mouvement spéculatif
alors cet hôte se répercutera pas
intégralement dans le dans le prix à la
pompe et même si c'est vraiment un
mouvement spéculatif on peut penser que
dans l'est dans les jours à venir le
prix du baril redescendre aux alentours
de 120 et auquel cas il n'y a aucune
raison pour que ça se répercute dans le
sur le prix à la pompe mais si par
contre c'est ces spéculations continuent
et si tendanciellement le prix
continuent à augmenter de tonnerre il
faut tout de même commencer à penser que
l'on vivra avec un prix à la pompe qui
va augmenter malheureuse
merci avec ar en va tout de suite
prendre là un exemple précis celui des
compagnies aériennes justement tout à
travers le monde tente de trouver des
solutions face à la hausse du carburant
c'est le cas aux états unis
reportage martine laroche-joubert et
pascal geoffrion l'envolée des cours du
baril de kérosène aux états unis les
passagers vont en payer le prix
liaisons supprimées avions remplis au
maximum tarifs en hausse certaines
compagnies américaines déjà critiquées
pour leur retard et leur service minimum
en vol prépare une mauvaise surprise
pour leurs voyageurs dès
l'enregistrement à partir du 15 juin sur
american airlines ils devront payer 15 $
de plus pour leur premier bagage 25 $
pour le deuxième 15 $ c'est exagéré pour
m je n'aime pas du tout ça on va juste
voyager avec nos bagages à main en fait
ils ont perdu mes bagages il ya deux
jours un surcoût dû selon les compagnies
à leur basculement dans le rouge au
premier trimestre elles seraient toutes
déficitaires
nous travaillons dur surtout les frais
compenser les pertes dues à la hausse
fulgurante du prix du fioul
nous cherchons à faire payer davantage
de services par nos passagers plus
inquiétant les économies de kérosène de
la compagnie continental airlines
régulièrement leurs avions atterrissent
à new york en procédure d'urgence avec
des réservoirs en limite de carburant
dépression serait même exercé sur les
pilotes pour épargner le fuel 98
millions d'américains prennent l'avion
chaque année les pilotes commencent à se
mobiliser pour assurer leur bien-être et
la sécurité
en bref sachez qu'un porte conteneurs
libérien a été repérée hier par les
douanes françaises dans le golfe de
gascogne
dans son sillage une pollution par
hydrocarbures d'une centaine de
kilomètres le navire ait été verbalisés
sachez qu'il n'ya pas de risque de
pollution sur le littoral
on revient l'économie avec la fin de la
semaine du microcrédit
les micro crédits ce sont des prêts de
moins de vingt-cinq mille euros qui
connaissent un succès croissant
un succès auprès des populations les
plus fragiles des hommes et des femmes
qui décident souvent de se relancer en
créant leur entreprise reportage
dorothée cochard et francis forget
pour connaître les besoins de ses
clients c'est vrai qu'il y ait la fa se
déplace chez eux
cédric lié nafaa monter une entreprise
dead à domicile c'est le client qui lui
donne ses instructions et ça serait du
nettoyage sa piste
et puis l'état gère surtout sa société
n'a qu'un an mais elle s'est développé
très vite il a tout de suite embauché un
salarié puis deux puis trois il a
aujourd'hui une centaine de clients et
pour monter son entreprise il n'a même
pas eu à convaincre deux banques
pour tout vous dire j'ai même pas essayé
c'est pas parce que je savais très bien
que ce n'est pas ça l'est pas fonctionné
surtout parce que je suis jeune donc peu
d'expérience mais surtout pas d'apport
conséquente
cédric a emprunté à un organisme
spécialisé dans le micro-crédit 700 à
800 euros un conseiller aide à monter
les dossiers et près de 1000 à 10000
euros
les trois quarts des personnes qui
décroche un microcrédit sont chômeurs ou
rmistes
seuls 3 % d'entre eux ne réussissent pas
à rembourser tout ce que nous essayons
de quillan c'est d'accompagner autant
d'idées autant devenir
oui autant de créativité que n'importe
quel entrepreneur ils réussissent aussi
bien sinon mieux
il rembourse mieux que les autres si ça
marche si bien alors comment sur ces
logos et qu'il y a un secret dix ans une
méthode à son bureau plusieurs fois dans
l'année l'entrepreneur reçoit la visite
gratuite d'un conseiller de l'organisme
prêteur s'est vu l'homme connaît la
gestion la comptabilité le droit
l'entrepreneur peut donc lui faire part
de tous ces questions pour développer
son entreprise m des offres de
parrainage de naître un peu plus
important que l'autre sens en avant m
des offres de parrainage
c'est une excellente initiative est une
excellente idée nécessaire peut être
aussi un intéressement du salarié qui
peut ramener d'autres contrats dix mille
sociétés secrètes ainsi chaque année
grâce au microcrédit 65% perdure et
celle de cédric linaf a est bien parti
pour être de celles là arrêtons-nous ce
soir avec le grand format sur une
question de société qui sont ces jeunes
qui se revendique comme étant satanistes
la profanation de tombes près de
perpignan il ya quelques jours à
replacer cette communauté entre
guillemets au coeur de l'actualité mais
s'agit-il justement d'une communauté
homogène attention aux amalgames combien
sont-ils et qui sont ils finalement
élément de réponse ce soir avec sophie
rodier sébastien lafargue le nom de sa
tante à gué sur une tombe
descroix inversée sur une autre c'était
il ya quelques jours à elne près de
perpignan
arrêté le lendemain le suspect âgé de 21
ans revendique un rituel sataniste les
cimetières sont particulièrement ciblés
par les adeptes de satan pascal launois
le maire de mesnil sur oger n'est pas
prêt d'oublier la date du 1er mai 2007
il a retrouvé les lieux entièrement
taguée les 3,9
ce sont des chiffres de satan et puis
l'a inscrit en grosses lettres walpurgis
nacht on a su a pas que ça voulait dire
la nuit des sorcières
une messe noire a été célébré plus de 80
crucifix sur le sol des bougies des pots
de fleurs renversés et surtout une mise
en scène macabre quarantaine de croix
étaient disposées de façon rectiligne
avant un gros dessins de de satan là
notamment l'étoile à cinq branches
par contre là bas on voit encore très
bien les les 3 6 devant les gendarmes
les profanateurs âgés de 24 et 36 ans
ont reconnu deux autres saccagent les
cimetières de cumières puis aux villes
et leur objectif former une étoile à
cinq branches le symbole du mal pour les
satanistes parraine de toutes les
religions
si on ne les avait pas arrêter leurs
exactions et et aurait continué
certainement aurait gagné en puissance
puisque à terme ils n'étaient
probablement question de d'excavation le
corps vandalisme ou rituelles satanistes
ces profanations sont de plus en plus
nombreuses
92 cas en 2007 une augmentation de 300 %
en un an
la plupart des auteurs appartiennent à
cette mouvance qui se dit adepte du
diable adolescent fragile ou adultes en
rébellion
principale source d'inspiration internet
et certains groupes de musique black
metal
les plus fervents se nourrissent des
têtes d'ancone l'avait fondateur de
l'église de satan en 1966 son
best-seller la bible satanique
aujourd'hui le problème c'est que nous
avons des jeux qui vont prendre la bible
satanique aux pieds la lettre et peuvent
faire dire aux versets de la bible cette
année en gros ce qu'il va être quand
certains versets laisse entendre que
l'homme ne doit rien laisser comme
obstacle à son désir sinon détruire cet
obstacle on peut comprendre que quelques
uns effectivement pas eu à lattes à 1996
kingersheim près de mulhouse
david oberdorf un adolescent de 18 ans
assassine le prêtre de sa commune de 33
coups de couteau et lui graver un
pentacle sur la main aux enquêteurs le
jeune homme dit avoir eu un flash
sataniste
cet homme était un ami proche du
meurtrier
aujourd'hui il souhaite rester anonyme à
l'époque selon lui leur bande de copains
étaient surtout attirés par les
ambiances de magie
certains d'entre nous pour tenez
suppressif est renversée être plus c'est
un peu dans l'air du temps à tous été
choqués de savoir que c'était lui quoi
était calme ils étaient sais pas a
présagé comme quoi il allait tuer
quelqu'un jours quoi avec qui on
s'endort petit trip satanique mais bon
personne pensait que ça irait jusque-là
quoi aujourd'hui le satanisme inquiète
dans ce lycée catholique parisien les
parents ont demandé un prêtre de les
informer sur cet univers
l'origine de ces jeunes vous avez parlé
la plupart du temps pas des pros pour ne
pas dire toujours sont des jeunes qui
sont assez intelligents qui ont une
certaine culture et qui peuvent
appartenir à des milieux tout à fait
favoriser des enfants qui se replient
petit à petit dans leur monde et qui
deviennent insaisissable pour les
parents on isole ces jeunes parce que
parce que voilà imogène c'est là où on
peut tromper engendré directement ou
indirectement chez ces jeunes une envie
parents de se suicider la mission
interministérielle sur les sectes estime
que les satanistes sont vingt-cinq mille
en france des petits groupes
d'adolescents pour la plupart ce
phénomène les pouvoirs publics le
maîtrisent mal
à tel point que la semaine dernière pour
la première fois les parlementaires ont
décidé de créer une commission denquête
7 l'histoire maintenant qui s'est
déroulé ce matin à chambéry un homme de
62 ans qui se déplace en fauteuil
roulant s'est retrouvé bloqué sur une
voie ferrée il a dû s'en sortir seul
tout simplement parce que personne n'a
répondu à ses appels à l'aide
explications lionel feierstein un amas
de ferraille et de plastique
c'est tout ce qu'il reste du fauteuil
roulant le ter l'a complètement broyé
sur ce passage à niveau de chambéry
heureusement sans faire de victime peu
avant 10 heures un homme handicapé
traversé la voie ferrée lorsque sa roue
ce bloc subitement dans les rails au
loin il entend un train arrivait
l'handicapé a juste le temps de
s'extraire de sa chaise et de ramper sur
le bas côté
je veux l'autre a arrêté puis j'ai vu la
chaise roulante en dessous du train et
la personne se relever et bouger quoi
alors été rassurés mais ça faisait
vraiment peur quelques heures plus tard
le miraculé n'en revenait toujours pas
salim et 6 62 ans et qu'il a échappé de
peu à la mort font des miracles chiffres
il me faut et mathieu grâce à dieu quel
filtre à rêver belgique
j'ai balancé mais je commence à rome
le tarif est l'âme par kilo bouteille et
moi je suis sauvé sa vie messick n'était
pourtant pas tout seul sur le passage à
niveau des automobilistes auraient
assisté à toute la scène mais sans
réagir
2 de deux gars j'ai déjà appelé pour me
sauver
dyson pour ne pas descendre de voiture
le miraculé de chambéry pourrait porter
plainte dès demain pour non-assistance à
personne en danger
c'est une première en france la présence
d'un ostéopathe au sein d'un service
d'urgences hospitaliers ça se passe en
région parisienne et vous allez voir que
l'expérience est plutôt concluante
reportage de jeu et blanc lapierre et de
iain moines lundi 8 heures 30 aux
urgences bilan du week-end entre les
médecins et au milieu des infirmières et
des internes cherchez l'intrus a noté 9
heures un ostéopathe en blouse blanche
qui arpentent les couloirs et cherche à
se rendre utile de des choses qu'on se
bat seul devant nous ok ce qu'il veut
c'est faire connaître sa profession
les médecins ne connaissent pas post
bâti sur le fond totalement donc moi on
peut aussi nous on a mission sociale de
leur faire connaître ce vaccin dans la
file d'attende tous ne sont pas de son
ressort
sa spécialité ce sont plutôt les
traumatismes les lombalgies
c'est justement le cas d'un patient qui
vient tout juste d'arriver et que le
chef de service lui propose de voir
ensemble allongé loup
visiblement vous avez réveillé joue en
scène en se levant
a priori rien de grave mais pour éviter
les anti-inflammatoires le médecin
confie son patient à l'ostéopathe mois
il était surpris de temps en temps que
l'examen ostéopathe mettait aboutissait
à nous orienter sur quelque chose de
totalement différent qu'on avait
peut-être pas vu sur une pathologie
d'apparence traumatique
c'est ça c'est des roses après examens
le sait au pad décide de faire une radio
mieux vaut être prudent dans la phase
aiguë soit sur 11 tentatives pour
manipuler qui a pas de point de
neurologique et qui a pas de point de
bascule vers et qui a pas de problème
discal suis soulagé avec les mains
pierre-alexandre y croit et c'est
bénévolement qu'il se rend aux urgences
de l'hôpital de poissy
chaque lundi matin la mort aujourd'hui
du cinéaste dino risi le père de la
commune italienne est décédé à l'âge de
91 ans il a réalisé plus de 50 films en
un demi-siècle et tourné avec les plus
grands sophia loren vittorio gassman ou
encore marcello mastroianni on revient
sur sa carrière avec mary pierce amitié
le jeune dino risi avait fait médecine
et s'était même spécialisé en
psychiatrie
avant de se lancer dans le cinéma dès le
début des années 50 et s'installe à rome
et tourne entre autres avec sophia loren
il excelle dans la comédie dépeignant la
petite et moyenne bourgeoisie parodiant
un mode de vie qui conduit à la perte de
certaines valeurs
tout cela dans une italie des années 50
en pleine mutation
en 1962 il tourne le fanfaron avec son
acteur fétiche vittorio gassman et jean
louis trintignant en 1974 parfum de
femme
l'histoire d'un aveugle donne la mesure
de sa maîtrise de la comique aussi dans
ses films unité apparente dissimule une
certaine amertume
hiromi de reese consciente des rires
c'est la dino risi avait fait jouer
nombre de collégiens français comme
coluche philippe noiret ou bernard blier
avec lui disparaît l'un des derniers
monstres de l'âge d'or du cinéma italien
il s'appelle prins rogers nelson mais la
planète musique le connaît mieux sous
son diminutif prins tout simplement un
artiste hors norme capable de jouer
d'une vingtaine d'instruments aux
frasques multiples qui fête ses 50 ans
et apparemment il n'a pas l'intention de
se calmer julien duperey sensuelle
électrique
il était à 20 ans il est toujours à 50
une quarantaine d'albums créer plus de
100 millions de disques vendus
ça fait un peu bilan pourtant à 50 en
prime ce n'est pas prêt de le déposer en
tant que chanteur je donne tellement de
concerts japon sans cesse au contact du
public premier album en 1978 depuis en
84 la gloire avec ça
ce géant d'1 mètre 57 fait tout de la
composition à l'enregistrement des
instruments un parent 92 conflit avec sa
maison dix cas qui appartient son nom
prins est remplacé par ce symbole love
star à femmes
volontiers provocateur il a aujourd'hui
retrouvé son nom et vend sa musique sur
internet
alors oui ce 7 juin il à 100 content
mais au royaume des quinquas de la
musique moderne il ne restera pas
longtemps le seul prince le demi siècle
c'est aussi ce qui attend à la fin de
l'été la reine madonna et le roi michael
jackson une découverte maintenant avec
le festival du mot qui se déroule à la
charité sur loire dans la nièvre des
mots en fête avec de la lecture des
théâtres du slam et des mots qui tombent
parfois du ciel on regarde tout cela
avec gianni briffa et sébastien
laffargue quelqu'un chercherait-il à
nous envoyer un message
tiens tiens des mots insaisissable dans
tous les sens parfois à double sens des
mots savants des mots doux de simples
mots à enfiler drôle de jeu de mots
justes pour l'instant débarque bien
les sévères je manque un peu
d'inspiration méchant que ça va faire
toujours à la recherche du bon mot un
homme de lettres
philippe delerm invité du festival
jusqu'à bien si c'était en fait on a un
rapport assez jubilatoire avec les mots
puisque en les compresses on joue avec
heures dans tous les sens et justement
les mots prononcés différemment au ty le
même sens
le festival présente trois mises en
scène du même extrait de pour un oui
pour un non de nathalie sarraute la mise
en scène le permis de comprendre la
phrase différemment et finalement
d'intérêt très près ce que les mots
différemment le mot ne doit pas faire
peur et qu'on peut justement s'en amuser
et apprendre des choses grâce à lui
alors sur les murs de la ville le
festival souffle des maupassant
grâce à ce peintre en lettres lui un mot
préféré il voudrait l'écrire et le crier
haut et fort rêve peut-être oui oui avec
un m majuscule le mot s'affiche en grand
jusqu'à demain soir à la charité sur
loire
malgré la pluie ah si vous le monde
voilà un peu de rêve avant de refermer
ce journal je vous rappelle l'une des
informations du jour c'est le soutien
officiel apporté en fin de journée par
l'ex candidate à l'investiture hillary
clinton à son ancien adversaire barack
obama désormais le candidat noir
américain est donc seul côté démocrate
dans la course à la maison blanche et la
firme ce soir qu hillary clinton sera au
premier plan de la bataille qui va
désormais l'opposé au républicain john
mccain
voilà pour l'essentiel de l'actualité de
ce samedi merci d'être fidèle à l'info
sur france 2 la météo avec isabelle
martinez 20h50 le retour de votre série
cold case avec trois églises
on se retrouve à 13 heures pour
l'information avec le journal 13h15 le
dimanche toute l'actualité de la semaine
vue par une personnalité notre invité
demain la ministre nathalie kosciusko
morizet très belle soirée à vous et à
demain j'espère
l'info en continu est aussi sur france 2
point fr